Imagine waking up on the beach before dawn.
The glimmer of light leads you to the shoreline.
Suddenly, a wave pulls you in
at first you use the direction of the waves to guide you.
But once you're in the open sea with powerful currents
bombarding you and very little light—
How can you be sure of where you are
and where you're going?
For a hatchling sea turtle
the answer is magnetoreception.
That's the ability to sense magnetic fields.
We know many animals use this
sixth sense for navigation.
What we don't know is exactly
how magnetoreception works.
Here's what we do know:
Earth itself is like a giant magnet.
The motion from its liquid outer core
generates a magnetic field.
Certain animals can sense this field
and use it as a compass to tell them
if they're heading in the right direction
and a map to give them sign posts
along the way.
There's two competing theories
for how magnetoreception works.
One is a chemical sensor/ the other is
a mechanical sensor.
The first theory is that animals have tiny magnetite
particles in their bodies that act as
magnetic receptors.
Magnetite is the most
magnetic natural metal on earth.
It's been found in many animals
that exhibit magnetoreception.
And it's thought that
it's the only potential sensor that
would be sensitive enough to capture
these incredibly tiny variations in
magnetic field strength that would allow
the animal to not just know
whether they're going north or south along the
magnetic field line but know the
precise beach that they need to get to.
The other theory is that animals possess
a protein in their eyes called
cryptochrome which allows them to see
magnetic fields.
Cryptochrome has been found in the eyes
of several migratory birds.
But we haven't proven either theory for a few reasons.
With magnetoreception you don't know where to look.
Magnetic fields pass invisibly through
the entire body so researchers don't  know exactly
where these magnetite particles or
cryptochromes would be attached to particular cells
and so mistakes are made  all the time.
And so far, cryptochrome experiments have only
yielded positive results in the presence
of magnetic fields much stronger than Earth's.
The frontier is now not so much at the animal behavior
level but actually getting inside the brains of
these animals and trying to find these
sensing cells and connecting them to the
neural circuitry.
It's not so much a question of which animals
have this sense but which don't.
So, researchers have said: "Why not humans?"
Maybe we had this sense at one point deep in our
evolutionary past and and lost it.
But maybe there's a vestige left.
Researchers in California and Japan have gone after
this holy grail one more time.
With a very specialized experiment.
One that relies on double blinding and
magnetic shielding and they're seeing
glimmers maybe even more than glimmers
of this magnetic sense in humans.
It's starting to be reproducible
and they're really excited about it.